[Music]
and not looking good news No submitted
by Beijing Bonner a chart shows the
jaw-dropping wealth gap between
Millennials and baby boomers well duh
baby boomers are out of age where they
have way more [ __ ] money right that's
not what they mean what do they mean
oh that's because Millennials are part
of the minimalist culture and baby
boomers they're a part of the keeping up
with the Joneses culture are we boomers
you guys your Millennials baby boomers
you have to be born during that time
like right after World War II 1946 and
1964 that's a baby boomer thank God for
where we're at the very end of
millennial like the very beginning of
the beginning so millennial is between
1981 and 1996 yeah yeah nice that's me
yeah but then there's a in-between is it
X Y Gen Xers are born between 1965 and
1980 yeah where why and then um how come
I feel like I relate to the Gen X cuz
you're right on the cusp wait wait
you're you're bored 1984 we do have
millennial traits though like like the
best a millennium our concept of new
wealth like doing paving your own way
all this stuff entrepreneurial spirit
that's that's kind of a millennial thing
where it's like I don't want to work too
traditional
yeah Gen X is like just clocking in and
be like yeah I'm good retired so what
they're very cool but the reporting here
is that when baby boomers like I said
who are born between 1946 and 1964 when
they hit a median age of 35 back in 1990
they collectively owned 21% of the
nation's wealth
right now or what is it um so boomers
both more than half which is 57% of the
nation's wealth while Gen X owns just
16% and Millennials you want to guess
how much we own five anymore guys wait
13 boomers on 57% currently currently oh
yeah so like when they were
what did you say 35 when they hit 35
when the median age was 33 15 18 20 20
percent of the wealth Oh in 21% yeah
because most people make their money
around the 60s oh we got Zuckerberg in
our average we got the Twitter guy that
Instagram guy we got we got some of the
Millennials now might be more there's a
lot of old money but then again the
boomer generation is the biggest bit of
the other thing is which we're not so
collectively they might be more so what
they're saying is currently boomers have
57 cuz sucks me know got like billion
15% and Millennials own 3% we very much
do you
Millennials are due to hit the median
age of 35 in four years we're at 3% that
makes that makes sense and we're poor
the plan yeah I mean so we don't know
much mother describes a lot of it
because boomer generation 2 they're the
biggest generation hmm population wise
right yeah so there's a [ __ ] ton of
those right find their own property and
[ __ ] yet so they were a social part of
an era that can afford property with a
with the regular wage my grandma's house
was $22,000 yep
and what Oh what was this this had it
been like late 60s something like that
if you go to Oklahoma wait upon by our
mansion for that much right now that's
for the Prairie don't yeah but you got
to watch out for tornadoes just other
things in Oklahoma adults under 40
excuse me have been accumulating less
and less wealth over the past 30 years
plummeting from owning 13% of the wealth
in 1989 to less than 7% today that makes
sense so at a median age of 35 Gen Xers
owned just 9% of the nation's wealth in
2008 which is less than half of what
boomers had at that same age and then
Millennials will have to triple their
net worth in the next four years to
catch up to Generation X at 35 X again
he said Gen X is one above us between
1965 and 1980 are those guys okay so
there are people in there like 40s and
50s my sister yeah okay that's why Gen Z
which is the one after us yeah or though
yeah around that that's my sisters yeah
so people that are in their twenties now
yeah eyes after night early 20s now and
late teens I think whoever was born
after 1996 they're more of a socialist
in their views yeah because it's a
different like they're not they see the
bad parts of capitalism like they were
born and around the time like you know
like the economy where essentially it's
a nation so they grew up during a time
when America was like not doing so hot
so what they're saying also is that just
wealth in general their perception of it
is like evil like now you know Occupy
Wall Street like banksters all this [ __ ]
right so that that has a more mentality
of like it's more socialist basically
it's more like you call equal economics
and [ __ ] like that in that that way that
wall has to shift oh so when the boomers
are gone
what money will trick lexicon to bring
up so they're saying that once boomers
pass they will be passing on their
estates to their heirs which is I mean
my grandma's deed right now it's being
called the great wealth transfer so that
will mean collecting 59 trillion dollars
in wealth and assets yes I get a house
in Armani that's going to the agencies
right because boomer kids are gens II my
addendum easy Jen's ease and Millennials
then it will be Lenny oh then it be
experts no ad boomer boomer kids are
Millennials and Gen Z or are they just
gens II of boomer kisses Gen Z no our
parents are boomers because my parents
are eggs yeah my grandma who because my
grandma is only what did you say 1940
something tonight 166 to 1964 yeah my
parents are boomers yeah sorry 113 1965
and 1980 which is she my dad had me when
he was 19 and then she had my dad when
she was 20 so we are like really close
and like in a dad oh [ __ ] I actually
broke the cycle because in 2010 I
suppose have kids basically I was gonna
keep that cycle going all that [ __ ]
here cycle oh yeah my cycle got broken I
was like borign will be 70 next year
yeah well that's your dad right yeah
that's my grandma so this little it's a
shift for me so here's a graph so it
says percentage of US household wealth
by age of generations median
well so they're also mentioning the fact
that Millennials have a good chunk of
that one point six trillion dollar debt
we go sailin student loan debt like kind
of like once you get out of school
they're kind of like stacked against you
like have to pay it back and stuff so
they're saying we were graduating around
the recession time when it was hard a
good job right
I know literally that year 2008 I turned
18 unlikely [ __ ] kidding me the time
when your boss would start getting job
rumours done [ __ ] up some [ __ ] I feel
like uh they were the mo there were the
ones that reap the most benefits cuz
like they didn't have World War two
right so their parents [ __ ] carries
that with that yeah like after World War
two that's when the economic boom
happened so then their parents that came
back from the war and all that they were
the hard workers that [ __ ] built all
the new neighborhoods and all that so
they got to live in that nice suburban
home and then they grew up with a good
economy and they got to buy all this
[ __ ] they're the ones that that did the
whole like consumerism culture what
about them what was that turn the blue
that was in the 60s so that would have
been affecting they were the left the
youngest boomer is born in nineteen
sixty four sixty yeah it's like a tail
under the other born didn't I said yep
so then they're also saying that the
Federal Reserve estimates that more than
a third of the 45 million Americans
burdened by the debts the student loan
debt are under the age of 30 that sounds
about right yeah that's exactly right
yeah because they're all students yeah
who else is gonna be [ __ ] by it do you
guys have a house didn't debt no not
anymore no I got I got lucky like when
we were picking out colleges that I
wanted to go to and stuff like I well I
only got accepted into two but the ones
that I got accepted to into were like
okay we have just enough as long as I
commute back and forth to Long Beach for
all four years I can afford it without
having to take out any loans oh good for
you they drive back and forth I did that
for four years but now I don't have any
debt in one setting aside the money to
allow me to go to school and to being
like yeah you're not dorming just
telling me like cuz I wanted to go dorms
like it's kind of like the experience at
least for like a semester that have been
cool yeah but ultimately I was happy
that I didn't because it allowed me to
get a job and then during that time I
was also like learning how to like work
and like just do retail kind of stuff
and like that that definitely put me in
a position to had just have more
experience and stuff but you got to stay
std-free a little bit
yeah I'm definitely like counting plus
up here I could've saved more mountains
too if I would have my dad said he was
like go to Community College first and
then transfer over which I didn't I just
went straight to like see sign and I
just paid all of it worried about that
though cuz I had so many friends that
got stuck in Community College like
trying to transfer but they couldn't get
classes and stuff and I was here I was
terrified that I would just like kind of
elongate out that process of my life so
I was like if I just go straight through
all four years for like a Cal State
because I didn't plan on going anywhere
else after that I was like I'll just get
it over with
yeah cuz the Community College strategy
worked during art time cuz after the
first week everybody got lazy
so everyone [ __ ] over themselves
during our time because financial aid
was hooked up yeah was in the middle
between you and you yes when I went it
was it wasn't that bad but it was
getting really hard to get classes yeah
we would get classes like that yeah and
and so if you couldn't get it the first
week you walk in or you can I sign it
you fit in don't be like sure cuz the
first week is [ __ ] people's lives
anyway
and people leave because they get lazy
right but now it's like there's money on
the line there's more pressure so people
on the line too like a lot of like
precious time that Wow do not cut the
classes that easy but [ __ ] man like give
it two weeks the whole school the
Community College becomes a ghost town
when we went yeah you know and they gave
good financial aid like they paid for
your classes they pay for your books
they give you extra spending money like
$3,000 just as much semester yeah I got
that
oh yeah they did give me some like that
and I did well five remember they gave
me one of these like a loan I remember
once at one point and I didn't need it
because I was like oh no I have like a
job now whatever and I like it was the
process just to give them back the loan
oh oh really I go through like all these
like there were loan or was it the grant
they might make Vander Laan hey man what
do I just know I was trying to give
money back to the school and it was the
whole process to give money back and I
was like you know I don't want to use
that I want to check this like I don't
need it like you guys ki you guys take
it back they made me told you so many
hoops to like continue paying like
whatever that was and I was like can you
guys just please think I don't want
anything to do with it yeah so it's like
it was dirty money
it's already yeah no it is may want to
damage it out of the damage is as soon
as possible get out
[Music]
[Music]